what hi I'm Peter Gallison how are you
youtube and i'm a professor history of
science and physics at Harvard I've been
at the World Economic Forum and quite
impressed with the seriousness with
which some of the environmental issues
have been discussed but as for the night
of 2009 i would say i think the
environment will lose out to the economy
but i think the hope for 2009 is that a
longer-term five-year say scope would be
considered because if we're going to
change things with respect to global
warming it's not going to be over the
next six months it's going to have to be
over the next five years with respect to
the where we think of alternative
generation power the way we think of the
efficiency of cars the way we think of
some of the fundamental issues that face
lesson try to reduce the carbon blood to
the environment thanks